hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the penultimate round
of the 2022 tata steel chess tournament
it's sam shanklin vs sergey karjakin and
this game uh very nicely shows how in
modern times it's not enough just follow
the moves you also have to be following
the tweets from the players themselves
about their own games but about the
other games as well and then it's all
the more enjoyable so uh
another dwell too long on it here i'm
just gonna share a tweet with you that
sam shanklin posted yesterday after his
very quick draw against the young sister
of duda he said not proud of what i did
today sadly when you play black you
don't always have a choice still this
was not a good example to set uh maybe
um
inspired by all the uh negative
attention that that a really quick draw
between magnus and karjakin got um uh he
he felt it was necessary to apologize
for uh for
such a short draw
but now he's playing against karjakin
and here
more action is happening on twitter but
we are going to visit this at around
move 10 so let's check it out shankland
with the white pieces opens with d4 we
have knight to f6 we have c for e6
knights the c3 and again bishop to b4
seems everyone prepared the nimzo indian
for for this tournament and uh as usual
queen the c2 and e3 are the top moves
here we've seen the uh immortal dodge
game uh between the fun forest and
anishigiri where a3 was played that also
went very well for white but here we
have f3 this is the clock variation and
uh well it is also not without poison as
you'll see so c5 by karjakin striking in
the center we have d5 grabbing more
space and now b5 trying to uh weaken the
the center if you capture here then
black and capture on d5 so here e4 this
is what white wants of course we want to
grab the full center and now d6 and here
bishop to d2 so just continuing
development with a6 and now a4
challenging that b51 and now you really
have to capture because there's too much
pressure so b captures on c4 we have
bishop captures on c4 and now knight b
to d7 uh giving up the the e6 pawn but
this is all very standard stuff we have
d captures on e6 f captures and now
bishop captures on e6 so for the moment
preventing black from castling but now
knight to e5 putting a lot of pressure
on that white king knight to d3 check
will be very unpleasant if it happens so
here we have bishop captures on c8 black
has to recapture the piece queen
captures on c8 and now bishop to f4
putting pressure on the knight but also
the queen now regains control of the d3
square
and now c4 so this is all very standard
stuff he has black is down upon but this
has been thoroughly analyzed and black
is very much okay here uh bishop
captures an e5 by sam d captures and now
knight to h3 uh
you have to develop the knight somehow
if you play knight the e2 then queen c5
is very annoying you you will not be
able to castle the queen can come to e3
is just a bad position for white so
instead after d captures uh e5 we have
knight to h3 by sam and now uh this is
now um
very very tricky as there are a couple
of games that reach this position but it
was uh at the disposition that um yan
nipponishi actually tweeted and he said
i just wonder if sam shanklin will
apologize for going uh for more or for
more or less known drawish line with
white of course if karjakin will recall
a few precise moves hashtag tata still
chess saying that uh okay um are kind of
trolling sam for tweeting yesterday that
he went for a quick draw with the black
pieces but now he's kind of going for a
draw with the white pieces uh but notice
this how he uh says uh of course if
karjakin will recall a few precise moves
and here
you really do have to make some precise
moves so here karjakin plays bishop to
c5 this is perfectly fine uh and also
it's a new move in the position rook the
b8 is also uh considerable bishop to c5
is a new move so now as of move 15 we
have a completely new game uh and now
queen to e2 uh we have rooked a b8 so
switching the move order a little bit
putting pressure on the b2 pawn
and now of course you can't capture on
c4 if you capture here bishop f2 check
you pick up the queen i hope none of you
were considering that uh so here knight
to f2 now we are ready to castle king
side and now uh you have to play bishop
to d4 this is kind of the idea behind
all of this but karjakin played queen to
b7 and now it's a most interesting
position what can you play here
obviously now it's a little bit
different
you can capture on c4 and perhaps you
even should but that would be a
completely different game uh the
difference is um
shanklin castles here first now the
difference is uh black doesn't have to
capture the pawn black can also just
play queen to beef or or or something
else but here karjakin captures the pawn
and now the position is winning for
white it's a very tricky move and it's
not easily uh sportable so feel free to
pause the video and win this game for
shankland while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well peace sacrifice and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is queen captures on c4 that's the good
stuff you have to give up the the knight
here because there's really not all that
much black can do now so bishop captures
an f2 check is played now of course
white cannot capture the bishop because
you're going to lose the rook on a1 so
kink the h1 uh and now again uh what can
you play here the the black king is not
uh going anywhere from the center of the
board you can't bring this rook into the
game it's a very very ugly position to
have with black and here we have queen
to b3 uh offering a queen trade but now
queen to c7 and this is the move
karjakin says that he missed uh during
his uh well uh
analysis um uh during the game and now
uh you really have some problems with
black the problem is now if you castle
and it seems like a perfectly fine idea
because okay rook 8 the b1 is the threat
but if we castle then we connect our
rooks uh here shanklin would have a
brilliant brilliant queen sacrifice if
karjakin castles here then we play rook
8 to b1 and now after queen to f7
offering a queen trade now shanklin
plays queen captures on b8 and beautiful
just a beautiful move uh rook captures
now rook captures nb8 with check and now
you have to block knight to e8 rook
captures an f2 and yes you have two
rooks and a knight for against the queen
and the knight
but the position is hopeless for black
for example g6 we have to create some
breeding room for our king knight to d5
now let's say king g7 you want to unpin
now comes rook fb2 threatening rook to
b7 to pick up the queen so king h6 and
now you're just gonna play rook to b7
attack the queen queen e6 uh and now
okay we could start with rook to e7
that's very strong but then you allow
some queen to c6 with some threats of
queen to c1 so let's say h4 and now
finally after you save the knight knight
to d6 now we play rook to a7 and we trap
the queen so there are a lot of winning
lines for white here and black cannot
get out of this so this is probably what
karaoke missed so he tried queen to b6
but this also doesn't help we have queen
captures on e5 by shanklin king to f7
and now knight to d5 and
here was the i think at around this
point uh nipple tweeted his second tweet
saying that uh he he jinxed it a little
uh and that's uh that's some a very good
twitter action right there uh and now
after knight to d5 again the position is
lost but you could lose it uh
straight up or you could just try and
put up more uh more of a fight here
knight captures and d5 was played and
that's completely
lost for black i will show you a um a
more durable line with queen to a7 now
okay you uh keep it try and keep an eye
on everything you're guarding the e7
square you're guarding the the rook on
b8 sufficiently so what can you do here
obviously rook captures an f2 that's the
stuff and we don't care if the queen
captures an f2 so if the queen captures
on f2 then we just go after the king
king queen c7 check king g6 now we go
knight d7 check uh came to h5 queen to
e5 check and that's just very sad king
h6 queen f4 check king h5 now g3 and
there is no defense against queen to h4
so what you would have to do after rook
captures an f2 uh you can't capture the
rook you have to bring the rook into the
game
uh but even this uh it doesn't really
work queen c7 check uh you force a queen
trade and after captures captures you
just up two pawns and of course uh
shankland will win this end game against
karjakin so after knight d5 uh okay
queen to a7 is a bit more resilient but
knight captures and b5 is played and
this is just lost queen captures on the
e5 king e7 we have queen back to e5
chair king of seven and now rook a to c1
and he was in this position animal 26
that uh sergey karakin resigned to the
game and shankland gets his first
victory of the tournament uh even though
he uh did not play uh you know poorly at
this tournament he played incredibly
well got some very strong draws uh for
example against magnus uh but uh so far
he was on minus two now he gets his
first win and he uh can maybe win the uh
final game to
uh finish the the tournament on 50 so
really a welcoming win for him and now
uh you can't really do anything about
this rook the c7 check is coming if you
block prevent this with rook to b7 then
we just play queen d5 check and after
king to e7 we play rook to c6 there's
not much you can do here queen d8 we're
gonna play rook e6 check king f7 and now
just a discovery here winning everything
uh that's it or if k7 we can even check
mate the king right away after king of
eight rook captures on the eight will be
checkmate so there's really not all that
much you can do here after rook 8 c1 he
resigned it's so hopeless that the top
engine move here is bishop to g3 uh but
uh you know the engines can sometimes be
funny without even realizing it uh so
that's a uh how hopeless a position is
uh so a brilliant game by sam shankland
and i would once uh again like to point
out this um part of uh of nippo's tweet
uh that says uh
if of course uh sergey karjakin will
recall a few precise moves so as you can
see uh in top level chess it's not all
that easy to recall a few precise moves
because players are bombarded with lines
they have to memorize the millions of
lines uh when i say millions i i mean
really a lot of lines uh and then of
course you will not uh be able to recall
uh everything at the
exact right moment so here very nicely
done by sam we'll see what happens in
the other games uh and yeah uh that's it
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank uh mike mccafferty deepak
robert arthur vladimirovnkovic
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this spectacular tournament
until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day